please
[Music]
Beyonce fumbles over her lyrics but
laughs it off with an assist from the
crowd it's pretty amazing it all went
down on Saturday during the Grammy
winners performance in Edinburgh where B
sang in front of a sold out audience
during a stop on her Renaissance tour
timeline
that's queen bee slaying in a custom
bedazzled nude bodysuit by lueve belting
out the lyrics to her 2022 track heated
but when B attempted to sing these
lyrics
like Coco Chanel it came out like this
[Music]
yeah instead of Coco Chanel she said
Coco Colonel remix
oh Lord I don't know
Beyonce laughed off the minor on stage
blunder and the crowd they got in
formation okay ladies now let's get
information they didn't miss a beat or a
lyric
[Music]
Beyonce kicked off her World Tour
earlier this month in Stockholm
performing 37 tracks for nearly three
hours with no opening act in front of 46
000 fans
it's her first solo run on stage in
seven years and with 57 scheduled
performances get this Forbes predicts
Beyonce could earn nearly 2.1 billion
dollars for this tour
[Music]
and speaking of Destiny's Child E.T
recently chatted with Beyonce's Dad
Matthew Knowles who served as the
group's longtime manager and he said
fans shouldn't rule out a reunion it's a
decision that the ladies would have to
make and I was certainly certainly
support that decision what would it mean
to have them get back together
I think the fans will be just Overjoyed
overwhelmed uh and and hopefully they do
one last time in their career hopefully
they give us one last album
uh who knows you never know because this
is entertainment a lot of things can
happen but for now he
'll say is one of the best entertainers
in the world if not the best today uh
and you know she always surprises me she
always takes it to a higher and higher
and higher level but giving back to her
fans
I think everyone walks out very very
surprised very fulfilled she's a true
Entertainer